but first please welcome the 26th United
States Secretary of Labor Thomas Perez
hey mr. secretary how you doing great to
have you here okay all right so you are
the Secretary of Labor a blue look at
you that's what my wife says and you're
the 26 now what no this wasn't from the
beginning of the Republic George
Washington didn't have a Secretary of
Labor right when did it start it's been
around over a hundred years hundred
years okay so and and we are almost at
or maybe we are at what they call full
employment right well we're not quite I
still think we got more room for
improvement but we've come a long way
and what is the unemployment rate the
unemployment rate right now is 5% 5% but
they usually say that is full employment
well guys it's like I mean America has
always said this that like 1 out of 20
people we can't take responsibility 1
out of 20 are just near do well losers
[ __ ] up suit not gonna get a job no
matter what you do come on admit that I
know a few ok so but but I'm sure you
heard Donald Trump at one point said
that that figure is completely wrong he
said it's more like 28 29 percent and
then he went or maybe even 35 in fact I
I heard because this is how he gets his
information you know I heard hearing
from cliff Clavin I heard it might be as
high as 42 what would America look like
if unemployment was at 42 well I mean
there's a reason his name rhymes with
dump you know my mother taught me right
okay you know in order to have that we'd
have to have my 95 year old grandmother
working we'd have to have my you know
high school sophomore work and I mean
the reality is this bill this president
inherited a mess the worst mess of our
lifetime the unemployment
was inching up to 10% to million plus
jobs lost in the three months before he
took office and now we've seen 73 months
in a row of private-sector job growth to
the tune of over 14 million jobs and
there's an Eeyore caucus out their
frustration for you guys if you watch
the Republican debates because they talk
about the last state neurs like they
didn't happen I'm gonna bring jobs back
my favorite factory zone comment is when
we hear from Ted Cruz and others that
Obamacare has been a job killer we've
had fourteen point three million jobs
created since the Affordable Care Act
was passed we've seen african-american
uninsured among African Americans gone
down by 50% Latino has gone down
substantially and so this fact free zone
is indeed fat-free but okay but but
honestly now there's some [ __ ] sorry
mom on the Democratic side too because I
mean they always talk about how
manufacturing you know weird food they
all the manufacturing jobs are gone
that's not true right aren't we actually
doing pretty well with men well you know
we've had the the last year has been
challenging and it's been challenging
for two simple reasons we have a strong
dollar and we have a global economy
outside the united states that is still
struggling and so when you have a strong
dollar it's harder to export things but
the six years before that we saw the
best growth in manufacturing since the
90s and I've visited people I visited a
guy in Ohio who had been a steel worker
for twenty five years lost his job we
helped him we're like match.com we met
you know workers who want to punch their
ticket to the middle class with
employers who want to grow their
business and we use the secret sauce of
training and now he works in specialty
steel and he said to me and I'll never
forget it you know Tom I used my brawn
for 25 years and now I'm using my brain
and that's the what's so insulting about
the eora caucus is that they do a
disservice
the ER caucus of Republicans who say
everything is bad you know they could
win the lottery on a Friday and they
playing that the banks were groves till
Monday right and and and what's so
frustrating is it does such a disservice
to the millions and millions of
Americans who were kicked to the side of
the road at this recession and have
climbed back through their grit and
determination and to sit there and deny
that is is such a disservice right okay
so what about minimum wage now that's a
big issue in this campaign burning wants
it to be $15 across-the-board Hillary
says only that in the big cities
otherwise twelve Elizabeth Warren says
if we pegged it to productivity since
1960 it would really be $22 and honestly
I don't know how you can live on even
$15 well the minimum wage stands for the
simple proposition that no one who works
a full-time job should have to live in
poverty and I meet so many people in
this job bill who are working a
full-time job and getting their food at
the food pantry I met a woman in Detroit
who fasts when you get out a lot I make
house calls and I see that you're on the
case and you know the the night before I
met her she has three kids she works in
the fast food area and she slept in her
car you know we can do better than that
as a nation and what the president has
supported and I support and the likes of
Elizabeth Warren and patty Murray and
other progressive Democrats support is a
12 dollar federal floor and then $15
elsewhere the first trip I took in 2016
was to stand with Andrew Cuomo for the
fight for 15 in New York and they've
succeeded I've spent a lot of time with
Eric Garcetti and I appreciate his
leadership in putting forth the $15
minimum wage here in Los Angeles and now
across the state upwards of 60 million
people now are living
right now yeah I read that in the
private sector over 80% of the private
sector is service industry it which
makes it sound to me like there are a
few rich people
and then a lot of people waiting on them
well here's the the reality of our world
right now is that we've made this
tremendous progress that I've pointed
out but the equal reality is that our
economy is still out of balance we have
way too many people you know the rising
tide needs to lift all the boats not
just the aughts
and the unfinished business of this
recovery is to make sure we have shared
prosperity and that's what I do every
day in this job is to make sure that
people have the skills to succeed and
and the retirement security to succeed
and and that they get paid for the
nation you are the first cabinet
secretary to be confirmed on a strict
party line vote you didn't get one
Republican vote right on cloture that
actually I'm both yeah that's amazing
because I mean no offense but this is
not one of those cabinet positions that
usually is that controversial it's not
one of the sexy ones again I try to
exalt it but you know it's it's it's not
Attorney General or secretary defense
say you know it's okay you know
labor come on give it to well I mean
here's here's the reality though
the sex talk is getting me a little
uncomfortable the reality is this and
here's why that happened before I had
this job I ran the Civil Rights Division
of the Justice Department in that job I
fought the mortgage industry because
they were screwing african-americans and
Latinos I fought again a total ID laws
you know part against voter ID laws in
Texas and elsewhere I took on Joe Arpaio
and other sheriffs who were abusing
people you know that was the world I
lived and I did that because you know
what America is better when everyone has
access to opportunity and made any
people in right doing the right thing
someone said that you're always welcome
to judge a person by the enemies they
make and I write my holiday card list
did not get longer and we're always
welcome here for that great job